في اخبار اخرى ذكرت وكاله الاناضول
للانباء ان نواب وزراء خارجيه كل من روسيا
وتركيا وايران وسوريا سيجتمعون في موسكو
يومي الخامس عشر والسادس عشر من اذار مارس
الحالي لمناقشه الملف السوري وكان وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو قد قال
الاسبوع الماضي عقب لقاء جمعه مع نظيره
الايراني في انقره ان نواب الوزراء
سيلتقون في موسكو للتحضير الاجتماعي وزراء
خارجيه الدول الاربع
من اسطنبول معنا مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج
عمر من تفاصيل اكثر عن ما جاء في وكاله
الاناضول بخصوص هذا الاجتماع المرتقب
عبد القادر هذا الخبر الذي نقلته الوكاله
عن مستشار او مسؤول دبلوماسيين تركي اكد
فيه ان نائب وزير الخارجيه براق اكثر
سيكون ضمن هذا الاجتماع الذي وصف بانه
اجتماع لمناقشه الامور التقنيه والذي
سيسبق اجتماعا على مستوى الوزراء هذا
الاجتماع الاول من نوعه على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه على الاقل بين يكون فيه وزير
الخارجيه التركي اضافه الى نظيره وزير
الخارجيه السوري في العام الماضي الحديث
عن المقاربه التركيه للاوضاع في سوريا
وتحديدا استئناف العلاقات ولو بشكل جزئي
مع نظام السلف في العام الماضي كان هناك
لقاء وصفه وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود
شاورما بانه لقاء سريع على هامش اجتماع
دول عدم الانحياز الذي حدث في جراد كما
ذكرت العالم الماضي في شهر اكتوبر وقال
الشؤون السوريه الهموم التركيه الان مصبه
على
مقارات الارهاب او مكافحه الارهاب اضافه
الى اعاده طوعيه للاجئين السوريين
الموجودين في تركيا في العاب ماضي ايضا
كان هناك زياره رفيعه المستوى هي الاولى
من نوعها حين زار وزير الدفاع الخلوصيار
موسكو والتقى بنظيره وزير الدفاع السوري
ولكن منذ ذلك الحين خفت الى حد ما الحديث
او او التركيز التركي على استعاده
العلاقات مره اخرى مع النظام ما ان الرئيس
اردوغان قال في مناسبات عده العاب المنصرف
انه لا مشكله من لقاح حتى على مستوى
الرؤساء طالما ان تركيا تحقق كل اهدافها
المتبثره بمحاربه الارهاب وايضا عوده
طواعيه للاجئين كما تعلم عبد القادر كان
هناك حديث في شهر نوفمبر المنصري عن عمليه
عسكريه تركيه محتمله في الشمال السوري
ولكن ربما بشكل بوساطه روسيه حاله دون
اداء تلك العمليه باتفاق بين الجانبين
عموما مره اخرى هذا الاجتماع سيسبق
اجتماعنا على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه هناك
شؤون تقنيه كما قال البيان ستناقش بين
الجانبين وبعد ذلك سيحدث هذا الاجتماع
لمشاركه ايرانيه ايضا مع وزيره خارجيه
روسيا وايضا سوريا